Universal plans to launch a monster movie
universe on the back of Tom Cruise's The Mummy.
The flick serves as a reboot of both the studio's
classic scary movie franchise and the Brendan
Fraser-starring trilogy.
However, despite lofty expectations and the
attachment of a huge star in Cruise, The Mummy
wasn't able to scare up many viewers in its
opening weekend, debuting to an underwhelming
$31.5 million domestic gross.
As it turned out, nobody but Cruise said this:
"Show me the Mummy!"
The disappointing start for the thriller likely
won't completely unravel Universal's so-called
"Dark Universe," but it definitely spells
trouble.
Here's why The Mummy was dead on arrival.
Critical curse
The Mummy was absolutely trashed by critics,
quickly falling below a 20 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes during its debut weekend.
Indiewire called the film "an irredeemable
disaster from start to finish, an adventure
that entertains only via glimpses of the adventure
it should have been."
Vulture said it hits its marks — but they're
"so low and so brazenly mercenary that it
doesn't feel like much of an achievement."
Rolling Stone quipped that it's "a monster
fail," while The A.V.
Club said it was "noisy but rarely exciting,
heavy on whizzing and whirling special effects
but light on wonder."
"Kick her ass!"
It's hard to find anything positive critics
have said about the movie — even those who
gave it "fresh" reviews mostly just deemed
it tolerable, rather than actually entertaining.
With so many other options out there, viewers
have little reason to head out to a movie
that critics had so thoroughly buried.
Wrongheaded reboot
The classic 1932 The Mummy is a far, far cry
from the 2017 version — something classic
cinema fans surely noticed when the trailer
for the new film dropped.
Starring Boris Karloff as the namesake monster,
the original flick relied on quieter, atmospheric
horror that kept viewers on the edge of their
seats without aggressively trying to scare
them at every turn.
The new movie, on the other hand, goes for
near-constant CGI thrills that are more visual
surprises than actual scares.
Fans of the original will see almost nothing
familiar in the reboot.
And younger audiences may be more familiar
with Brendan Fraser's Mummy trilogy anyway.
Those movies emphasized campy fun and had
help selling its story with its 1920s setting,
which gave a period-appropriate feel to the
classic monster tale.
Cruise's version, meanwhile, takes place in
the present day, a move that arguably takes
the film even further from the classic adventure
story it's trying to be.
Rehash fatigue
Hollywood has spent the last several years
turning to familiar properties audiences loved
in the past.
But the string of flops from 2017's crop of
reimaginings suggests filmgoers might be getting
tired of all the modern revivals.
King Arthur: Legend of the Sword, Dwayne "The
Rock" Johnson's Baywatch, and the fifth Pirates
of the Caribbean flick all fell far below
expectations.
All of these films had something in common:
rotten reviews and bad word of mouth.
As successful recent remakes, reboots, and
sequels like Beauty and the Beast and The
Fate of the Furious have shown, audiences
are only willing to turn out to see overly
familiar films if they're actually any good.
Cart before horse
Universal's Dark Universe franchise is set
to include beloved characters such as the
Invisible Man, the Phantom of the Opera, and
Frankenstein, among many others.
"It's alive!
It's alive!
It's alive!"
Well, let's not be too hasty, Doc.
The studio may have killed the whole enterprise's
chances at success by announcing it before
even making a single successful film, hobbling
The Mummy and making its attempt at world-building
seem disingenuous to audiences.
As many of the reviews pointed out, the movie
struggles with that world-building, leaving
the narrative feeling slow and labored, with
heavy exposition interrupting the action.
Launching the Dark Universe right off the
bat without trying to first create a successful,
fun film played a big role in The Mummy's
overcrowded feel, and could have a negative
effect on the rest of the franchise going
forward.
Star power-outage
Internationally, big names like Tom Cruise
still sell movies.
But at home, data shows that people just don't
care as much about a movie's star power as
they once did.
Recent examples include Dwayne Johnson in
Baywatch and Tom Hanks in The Circle — high-profile
flops highlighted by the surprising performances
of 2017 sleeper hits like Get Out and Split,
neither of which had huge names attached.
So what gives?
For one thing, more stars are moving to movies
on TV and streaming, with huge names like
Brad Pitt crafting films for Netflix and stars
like Matthew McConaughey and Nicole Kidman
making prestige TV like True Detective and
Big Little Lies.
The number of films in theaters is also increasing,
meaning that viewers simply have more to choose
from.
Buzz need
Marketing is important, but organic buzz is
what can really make a film blow up — and
The Mummy never really had any.
A Fandango poll looking for the most anticipated
film of the summer didn't even put it in the
top five, while a look at social media buzz
on Twitter showed that the film wasn't among
the top five most-tweeted-about movies the
months leading up to its release.
The summer box office is overcrowded with
huge movies, and without positive word of
mouth, it's hard for one movie, even one with
an established name like The Mummy, to break
out.
"What are you thinking?"
I'm thinking we're probably going to die here."
"I knew it!"
No wonder
Making matters worse, The Mummy faced one
of the toughest competitors of the summer
during its opening weekend: Wonder Woman,
the juggernaut that beat the box office with
an expectation-shattering $103 million opening.
Wonder Woman also used its stellar reviews
to earn the biggest second week for any film
in the DC Extended Universe franchise thus
far.
The Mummy likely couldn't have topped Wonder
Woman's second-week grosses even if it had
received positive reviews.
Salvaged overseas
The box office market is very different overseas,
and it's provided a rescue for quite a few
domestic flops in recent years.
This looks to be the case for The Mummy, which
gave Cruise the largest international opening
of his career.
The film did best in Cruise-friendly territories
like China, South Korea, Russia, Mexico, and
Taiwan, where the star's name continues to
carry quite a lot of weight.
"It's not an exact science, this business."
This may offer a lifeboat for the future of
the Dark Universe, which has a few other big-name
stars attached for upcoming movies, including
Johnny Depp as the Invisible Man.
Still, The Mummy's scary lack of domestic
appeal adds a troubling wrinkle to the future
of Universal's monster movie initiative.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!